the apocalypse is nigh my friends
politico reports china vows to encircle
taiwan with military drills in response
to pelosi's visit tensions reach their
most precarious point in more than a
quarter century forget the politico let
me show you the visual
from 12 p.m august 4th to 12 p.m august
7th the chinese people's liberation army
will conduct important military
exercises and training activities
including live fire drills in the
following maritime areas and their
airspace
they're just announcing they're going to
surround taiwan and start firing
into the air while nancy pelosi is in
taiwan
i don't think anything's going to happen
well i'll put it this way this is
happening
i don't want to be
naive and optimistic or biased to assume
nothing could happen you know because we
often talk about the battle at fort
sumter fort sumter when no one thought a
civil war would break out so they're
like picnicking on the hillside
are we falling into that trap are we
sitting here being like ah they're not
gonna do anything to pelosi or
no we we have to fear corporate and
medical tyranny not war on country owned
country they do not want to pose
two great economies against each other
they can suck us dry of our interest
back to the federal reserve right now
we're not
we're not staring down real nuclear war
i don't think no we could be staring
down some stupid sanctions
which they're already doing right on
taiwan they're banning
imports of fish or whatever it is um i
don't know if it's from response to this
but i mean at the end of the day when
you're banning imports you're shooting
yourself in the foot uh by
reducing by um reducing the amount of
resources that can get into your country
so ultimately chinese consumers will be
the ones who are hurt by these types of
sanctions i mean it's true but
you see those videos of all the chinese
citizens like outside the banks they're
unable to pull money out yeah i mean at
a certain point china says it's now or
never yeah is it and considering how
close taiwan is
to china and considering china considers
taiwan to be china
there's a line you know what i mean like
the ccp might just say you know what
that's the line our economy is is shot
our people we can't people can't
withdraw money from their banks we're
already facing this threat of you know
trump and the united states as an
economic force is probably not going to
last
they might be thinking this is why i i
don't want to you know
exaggerate what might happen but i just
want i also don't want to ignore the
possibility china could be looking at
this like
we can wait two years donald trump gets
reelected trade war again economic
crisis on our end we start losing
manufacturing or they can say you know
what
show up our defenses now make the move
before they do
and that might work out
i hate to say it but it might work out
okay
it might work out just fine as long as
the united states doesn't go after them
with aggressive military action
ultimately what's going to happen
i mean i feel for the people in taiwan
absolutely i do
i do but
is taiwan a sovereign nation
i mean if you ask americans the answer
is yes do what are americans what's that
based on like what's their basis for
making that assessment that taiwan is a
sovereign nation
like the history of taiwan and china i
don't know what do you mean officially
the republic of china this is where the
old chinese government fled when mao
staged his insurrection right so
basically this occupying force the ccp
isn't the real government of china it's
the republic right but the united states
officially does not recognize taiwan as
its own country right and so
doing that would be a huge leap
huge leap and it would have a lot of
implications
yeah but i don't think i don't like
nancy pelosi all that much i think she's
a hypocrite on the uh when it comes to
education for example um
but
i don't think her going over to taiwan
and meeting with people is
going to be considered a real act of
aggression for one because it's not but
um i think we i think the chinese
government might be more concerned about
us funding taiwan and actually providing
subsidies to them which could
change the the dynamic of power in the
future um yeah i'm surprised so many
people
exist in this political mindset that
like china is a bunch of imbecile
children like do you think russia is
sitting there going like oh those
ukrainians keep eating fighter jets
somehow or do you think they're saying
we're at war with america right oh they
totally do it's trying to sit in there
being like we know the us doesn't think
taiwan is a country or do you think
they're saying the us is funding taiwan
so they can rebel against us and if it
wasn't for your involvement we would
have taiwan now
i think it's probably somewhere in
between
i think that that i think it's explicit
well the united states is definitely
being an economic opportunist in this
and i think that we're really our
government is pushing it as far as they
can go
but if china actually stepped in and put
troops on taiwan and started a situation
like like we're seeing in russia and
ukraine
i don't know if the united states is
going to send troops over i i agree i i
think
we've got uh you know the strike group
carriers warships that are heading into
the region which is why china's
announcing this because they're
basically saying back off
i obviously the us is the only reason
china hasn't just invaded taiwan i mean
maybe the fact that taiwan does have its
own defense but of course we're we're
supporting them in many ways we we
we utilize taiwan for tons of business
if it weren't for us they would not have
as much economic development and they
wouldn't have the resources to defend
themselves it looks like at the same
time we uh benefit china with with trade
as well so they might not want to have
an act of aggression against taiwan
because they don't want to lose
economic trade no not if they're already
hurting not if not if trump's already
started a trade war with them not if
their banks are already in dire straits
not at the sentiment of the american
people is that in couple two to four
six years we're going to strip all the
manufacturing away from china stop doing
these deals with chinese-made products
if they're planning ahead
i gotta say it looks to me like the next
four years is going to be made in
america donald trump he's running again
he's he's
i i they have to pull joe biden out that
right there is red flag sirens for for
the democrat chances of winning what are
they going to do aoc
actually we have the oh we have the
article we're going to talk about yeah
and and i
there's no way aoc beats trump
knock on wood because i maybe something
happens but if trump wins he's going to
say
he's exactly what he said you remember
when he had that quote michael moore
brought it up he went to the auto
manufacturers and said if you make your
cars overseas i will charge you a 30
tariff to bring them in and no one will
buy them yep and then what do we see in
michigan they reopen plants they brought
the cars back from the plants from
mexico and then as soon as trump's out
alls and they shut it down they're
moving things back out again china knows
this they know it better than we do i
can only imagine that they're like
looking at their watch saying we hope
trump doesn't win
according to wikipedia taiwan is part of
the republic of china which is a country
and taiwan there's 168 islands in the
republic of china taiwan makes up like
99.98 percent of the land mass
so it is its own country the republic
oh okay so
the last poll uh that was released out
of the hill has trump up against biden
by what eight points it's like not even
close um
biden's done i mean did you see that
there was a video that came out that
everyone thought was a deep fake
because his eyes are like lasered and
he's like you guys
it's like
i'm sorry i don't i don't think it's a
deep thick i think they just gave him
uppers well is he going to get better or
worse between now and 2024. that's a
real question it's like they're they're
they're giving these pills and it's like
squeezing blood from a turnip you know
like there's nothing left to get out of
this this man they're probably pumping
him full of things to fortify his blood
this poor man
they're they're he's getting how much
you want to bet he gets like iv
treatments oh no for real oh i used to
get them yeah you can get all kinds of
nice vitamin cocktails and you can put a
lot more in it than that we get nad
because joe rogan you know he told me
he's like you got to do the nad and then
i was like i'm not going to do as much
as he does we'll do it sometimes yeah
you guys think gavin newsom has any shot
at the democratic primary yes absolutely
i just don't think they can win yeah but
look you know
you know we can't i can't see everything
you know i've made some good political
predictions i've made some some big bad
ones and you know for the most part it's
like here's what i think might happen
and that's why i try to just say you
know what man
all that matters is it's primary day
right now
midterms are really really close three
months away
forget who you think is gonna win just
get all your friends every single one
you know what you should do tell your
friends you're gonna go vote call them
all up every single one post hey we're
meeting here this time we're all going
to go vote and um like if you live in
the right in the same district or
whatever and if they if they're
grumbling or whatever just say hey we're
going to go out for pizza
on the way we're stopping to vote then
we're going to get pizza there you go
that's what you do i think eric's going
to win that race
i do too yeah wonderful i mean trump
trump endorsed him so
in missouri you saw that yeah he's
probably got something good going for
him if what is trump you may or may not
have endorsed him you were mentioning
like trump trump endorsed someone else
with the wrong last name in first year
yeah wasn't that did he laugh was that
jd vance's race like he endorsed one of
the first names and then the last name
of the other guy and everybody's like
it's really just trolling us on all and
all these assessments this is this is
what i love about donald trump you know
it's like
his foreign policy was some of the best
i've seen
um and i i can talk all about getting
our troops out of the middle east north
korea i bring it up all the time because
these things i think are important i i
absolutely despise i did a segment today
talking about china talking about pelosi
uh middle east you know with a drone
strike
on that taliban leader and all this
stuff and i just absolutely despise
the american war machine a bureaucratic
state military industrial complex and
intelligence industrial complex
if they if they came
and were honest with legitimate purposes
for what the u.s were to do overseas i'd
be like wow this is serious stuff it's
just lying everything is just not true
and it's exemplified by
nothing they ever say aligns with what
the supposed interests are you know like
uh here's an example what really pisses
me off is joe biden's quid pro quo with
ukraine when he says you're if you don't
fire the prosecutor you're not going to
billion dollar loan guarantee then he
says i did this because the prosecutor
was corrupt and then we got someone in
who was good the funny thing is the
prosecutor was investigating baris the
founder of barisma as soon as biden gets
him fired the founder came back to
ukraine and then as soon as trump came
in the founder fled sounds a whole lot
like biden was covering ferberism
because his son worked there so don't
give me this bs they're spitting in our
faces now they talk about the need for
taiwan and the south china sea i'm like
you are just liars the gulf of tonkin
that that happened in what was the 70s
the the false flag to get involved 60s
false flag you're right like 60s to get
us involved in vietnam i was not alive
i grew up hearing the story about how we
were attacked and then i think it was in
the 2000s they finally admitted like oh
yeah we kind of staged that
so we could force america so that we
could draft people so you know what i'm
done with it donald trump can come in
and he can say we're making all the
troops out i'll be like good you deserve
it because the united states is not
justified i know china's got africa and
south uh south american oil
exploration and development and the belt
and road initiative these things are a
big threat we're going to have a
multi-polar world where there's
potential for real-world conflict but
the united states the the deep state
bureaucratic state military industrial
complex has done nothing to unify
americans to justify any of these
incursions so you know what i want
donald trump to come in fire everybody
start fresh that sounds good to me i'm
with you i used to be very
anti-imperialist in general just like
down with the military industrial
complex and then now recently i'm like
replace it with what
there's gonna be a military complex on
earth whether it's the american one or
the chinese one or whatever yeah but it
could be national defense as opposed to
national offense yeah well but that's
what they think that's what they say
right like the reason we we are in
afghanistan is because they're like well
we leave it's a power vacuum you'll get
terroristic
you'll get china and i'm like hey yeah i
hear all that but you lied to us to
bring us there okay so you know no
that's not how i apply you need to give
us a legitimate justification and was
the afghanistan war a huge success did
we
change why did we just leave it was a
success for halliburton no i mean yeah
what else made money off of it they they
i it's just
look i've been following some of this
stuff
i'm not gonna pretend to know more than
those who have access to confidential
information i don't so my position is
only yo all i know is you're wrong and
you're lying and whenever we say please
justify what you're doing they give us
bs
barack obama killed a 16 year old
american citizen abdulrahman al-awlaki
and they said oops
i'm like that's it sorry you're done my
my my my uh consent has been rescinded
for what you what you were doing i'm a
little kid i'm like i don't know all
about this stuff i get older i'm like
hey i got questions about this then
obama's like we're gonna come in and
pull our troops out and then he gets in
he goes i'm going to blow up those kids
too many right i'm just like dude no
none of this trips out drone strikes in
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you